We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine to David P. this is pretty funny.
Last week we had a voicemail that I didn't
really understand which said, Hey, David is
the entire Bernie Sanders thing, a distraction
and I wondered which thing and a distraction
from what we have now someone following up
who is concerned about another distraction
on the program. Take a listen to this.
Hi David, this is Michael from Missouri. I
wanted to just call and ask you about the
whole producer Pat thing. I mean, do you think
that it's a distraction? Thanks.
Yeah. You know, I do think that the entire
producer, Pat thing is a huge distraction
and that's why we're going to be asking him
about it. On today's bonus show where we will
discuss, there is a growing movement that
says TV producers are doing something ethically
wrong by putting Rudy Giuliani on TV because
he just lies. That's all he does. Joe Biden
is one of those people. We will talk about
that. We will also talk about the investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails. Now you're
probably thinking, I'm kidding. I'm not kidding.
The Trump administration is now in the wake
of the impeachment inquiry in the wake of
being caught red handed. Not even saying that
they were trying to collude as an understatement,
forcing collusion with Ukraine. They are now
ramping up an investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails. It is still going on. We will also
talk about a very interesting interview with
former British prime minister David Cameron,
who is calling the Brexit referendum that
led to everything we have seen since January,
2120 16 the day of that vote, his greatest
regret, and it still is not clear, in fact,
it is sort of more and more clear.
It's unclear that Brexit is going to happen.
You could also argue it is more clear that
it is not going to happen, but we'll have
that conversation on the bonus show, all of
those stories and more including the distraction
of producer Pat as the voicemail caller said
on today's bonus show, two ways to get access,
become a member@joinpacmandotcombecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show and remember you can
call the voicemail number 24 hours a day and
many of you do. The number of voicemails we
get between like two and 5:00 AM Eastern time
is uh, is high. It's very, very high. Two.
One nine two David P is the number and I hope
you will join me this evening for a live stream
on Twitch at Twitch,
T V slash David Pakman. Follow me, subscribe
there with Twitch prime and I hope you'll
join me this evening, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].